do you have advice for a programming
beginner on How to Learn Python the
right way
find something you actually want to do
with it
if you say I want to learn skill X
that's not enough motivation you need to
pick something
and it can be it can be a crazy problem
you want to solve it can be completely
unrealistic
but something that that challenges you
in into actually learning
coding in in some language
and there's so many projects out there
you can look for like that that doesn't
have to be some big ambitious thing it
could be writing a small bot if you're
into social media you can write a read
about or a Twitter bot or uh or some
aspect of automating some something that
you do every single day processing files
all that kind of stuff nowadays you can
take machine learning components and and
sort of
plug those things together so cool stuff
with them so that's actually a really
good example so if you're interested in
machine learning the state of machine
learning is such that like a a tutorial
that takes an hour can get you to start
using uh pre-trained models to do
something super cool and that's a good
way to Learn Python because you learn
just enough to run this model and that's
like a sneaky way to get get in there to
figure out how to import stuff how to
write basic i o how to run functions and
I'm not sure if it's the best way to
learn the basics of python but it could
be nice to just get fall in love first
and then figure out the basics right
yeah you can't expect to Learn Python
from a one hour video of course I'm
blanking out on the name of of someone
who
who wrote a very funny blog post where
he said I see all these ads for things
like
Learn Python in 10 days or so and he
said the goal should be Learn Python in
10 years that's hilarious but I
completely disagree with that I think
the criticism behind that is that
the the places just like the blog post
from earlier the places that tell you
you learn python in five minutes or 10
minutes they're actually usually really
bad tutorials so the thing is I do
believe that you can learn a thing
in an hour to like get some interesting
quick like it hooks you I mean this but
it just takes a tremendous amount of
skill to be that kind of educator
Richard Feynman was able to condense a
lot of ideas and physics in a very short
amount of time but that takes a deep
deep understanding and so yes of course
the actual I think the 10 the 10 years
is about the experience the pain along
the way and there's something you have
to practice you can memorize the syntax
but well I couldn't but maybe maybe
someone else can but that doesn't make
you a coder yeah actually coding has
changed in fascinating ways because so
much of uh coding is copying pasting
from stack Overflow and then adjusting
which is another way of coding and I
don't want to talk down to that kind of
style coding because it's kind of nicely
efficient but you know where that is
going
I use it every day and it really yeah it
writes a lot of code for me and usually
it's slightly wrong but it still saves
me typing because all I have to do is
like change one word in a line of text
that otherwise it it generated perfectly
and like
how many times are you looking for like
oh what was I doing this morning I was
looking for a begin marker and I look
was looking for an end marker and so
begin is
blah blah blah search for begin this is
the begin token and then the next line I
type e and it it completes the whole
line with end instead of begin that's a
very simple example sometimes it it sort
of
if I name my function right it writes a
5 or 10 line function
and you know python enough to very
quickly then detect the issues so it
becomes a really good dance partner then
it doesn't save me a lot of thinking but
since I'm a poor typist I'm very much
appreciative of all the all the typing
it does for me
much better actually than the the
previous generation of suggestions that
are also still built in vs code
uh where when you hit like a DOT
it it tries to guess what the type is of
the variable to the left of the dot and
then it gives you a list a pop-down menu
of what the attributes of that object
are but copilot is much much smoother
than that well it's fascinating to hear
that you use GitHub copilot uh do you
think do you worry about the future of
that
um did the automatic code generation
the increasing amount of that kind of
capability are programmers
jobs threatened
or is there still a significant role for
human our programmers jobs threatened by
the existence of stack overflow
I don't think so it helps you take care
of the boring stuff and you shouldn't
try to use it to do something that you
have no way of understanding what you're
doing yet
a tool like that is always best when the
question you're asking is please remind
me of how I do this
which I
I could do I could look up how to do it
but right now I've forgotten whether the
method is called Foo or bar or how you
what the shape of the API is does it use
a builder object or a Constructor or a
factory or
uh something else and what are the
parameters it serves that role it's like
a great assistant
but the creative work of sort of
deciding what you want what you want the
code to do is is totally yours